speaking less than an hour before the
end of the trading day
president Trump sought to reassure
Americans and investors that his
administration was on top of the
coronavirus crisis the markets were
already in positive territory and
remained there throughout Trump's news
conference by the closing bell all three
major indices were up more than 9%
recouping most of their losses from the
day before
Europe's markets also up on the day
perhaps most relieved energy companies
on the announcement that the US Energy
Department would buy up oil for the
country's strategic reserves pushing up
crude oil prices as well as energy
stocks
well relief rally and also I think the
the concerns that we all had yesterday I
mean the the fear and the anxiety and
the worry that we wouldn't see another
up day but then here we get this today
is is just proof that this market is
resilient we will get past this
there will be more up days ahead it was
a sharp contrast from earlier in the
week when the president's ban on travel
from Europe with only a vague promise of
economic relief for affected industries
sent markets spiraling downward more
than 20% below market highs into what's
known as bear market territory a
positive end to what has undoubtedly
been one of the most tumultuous weeks in
Wall Street history but there's more
uncertainty ahead Congress has yet to
approve a financial package for those
affected by the virus and perhaps more
importantly new cases in the United
States are still on the rise Kristin
salumi al Jazeera New York